Forschungsteams weltweit haben eine serie gewaltige sonneneruption
verzeichnet eine große gefahr für die internationale raumstation
ihre besatzung musste wegen des gigantischen
protonen sturms schnell in deckung gehen und auch auf der erde haben
sonneneruptionen solchen ausmaßes folgen wie die
Gefahrensituation auf der ice es genau ablief wie bedroht die besatzung wirklich wahr und inwieweit das
Brodeln der sonne auch für uns menschen auf der erde gefährlich ist jetzt den klicks und science fiction herzlich willkommen
Die aktuellen sonneneruption stufen forschungsteams in die höchste der fünf bestehenden kategorien
einstufe xi brechen alle rekorde
die klassen a b c und m bezeichnen sonnenaktivität von nicht solch einem gewaltigen ausmaß
Am vierten september hatte die jüngste serie mit schwachen ausbrüchen begonnen zwei tage später
Folgte dann eine der stärksten eruption der letzten zwölf jahre und gleichzeitig eine der fünf heftigsten die hier auf der sonne beobachtet worden war daraufhin
folgte dann einen sonnen beben von forschungsteams auch koronaler massenauswurf
Genannt solch eine eruption hat die energie von mehreren achtung
milliarden- atombombenexplosion jetzt konnten forschungsteams auch herausfinden, wo der
ausgangspunkt für die eruption serie liegt und zwar am rand der sichtbaren sonnenscheibe
Der sich von der erde wegdrehte die nasa hat die eruption mit
ihrem solar dynamics observatorien
Festgehalten auf einem bild ist ein greller uv blitz zu erkennen grob gesagt sind sondern der option
Elektro magnetische vorgänge innerhalb, des sterns aus der sonnenatmosphäre wird dabei eine gigantische wolke aus gas
herausgeschleudert unvorstellbar heißt die dabei
ausgestoßenen teilchen genauer protonen können
im weltall geschwindigkeiten von mehreren millionen kilometern pro stunde erreichen und dabei auch
problemlos die hülle eines raumschiffes durchdringen eine große gefahrenquelle also tatsächlich für die internationale raumstation für die
Iss wenn man bedenkt dass ihnen gut 400 kilometern?
Höhe über der erde kreist ein teilchen schauer kann ohne den großteil der schützende wirkung der erdatmosphäre
tatsächlich gravierend sein worüber kaum etwas in den medien zu erfahren war
Die besatzung auf der iss hat am 10 september also vor wenigen tagen als der proton sturm immer stärker wurde dann tatsächlich den befehl
alert also alarm erhalten daraufhin musste die besatzung einige zeit in einem schutzraum ausharren
zudem bekamen sie die anweisung weniger geschützte bereiche der raumstation aufgrund der starken strahlung zu meiden
roskosmos die russische raumfahrtbehörde
betont trotz allem dass das alles eine reine
vorsichtsmaßnahme gewesen sei denn die iss sei sehr sicher konstruiert die spannende frage jetzt können solche eruptionen
auch der erde und menschen darauf gefährlich werden der abstand zwischen sonne und erde beträgt
150 millionen kilometer dazu kommt die schützende wirkung der erdatmosphäre
Und trotzdem hat die sonnenaktivität auch folgen für uns sondern optionen formen
plasmawolken und dadurch entstehen magnetische stürme in unserer erdatmosphäre das problem solche ausbrüche sind nicht wirklich
vorauszusehen doch die signale einer sonneneruption erreichen die erde innerhalb von etwa nur acht minuten
Dann dringt röntgenstrahlung in die ionosphäre ein und verändert die eigenschaften
So dass funkwellen sich nicht mehr ausbreiten können vor allem kurz und ultra
Kurzwellen sind betroffen dort findet vor allem der amateure mobilfunk stadt auch gps war vom aktuellen
sonnensturm betroffen also das global positioning system
Es gibt auch einige wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler die die sonnen ausbrüche mit naturkatastrophen ihr auf der erde in verbindung setzen
Taifune erdbeben und auch solche hurricanes wie er will und immer
könnten indirekt folgen von sonneneruptionen sein klingt logisch wenn man bedenkt welch eine starke
Energiequelle die sonne da stellt er optionen sind nach ansicht einiger forschungsdienst zwar nicht der direkte auslöser solcher naturkatastrophen
Doch selbst kleine störungen der sonnenaktivität könnten lokale wetterbedingungen demnach verstärken und es gibt weitere
indirekte konsequenzen die ein starker sonnensturm mit sich bringt ein forschungsteam aus den usa hat beispielsweise
ermittelt dass bis zu zwei drittel aller amerikaner
durch einen starken sonnensturm vom strom und
telekommunikationsnetz abgetrennt werden könnten der schaden für die wirtschaft und infrastruktur wäre enorm und beträgt den schätzungen zufolge
Acht bis zu 40 milliarden us-dollar täglicher in dem betroffenen nächten anfang des monats waren übrigens vor allem in
skandinavien kräftige polarlichter zu sehen durch dem dichte und geschwindigkeits wechsel
Im sonnenwind entstehen schwankungen, im magnetfeld elektrisch geladene teilchen des sonnenwinds schlagen je in einem
Ring um süd und nordpol ein da sie den linien des magnetfeldes folgen durch ihre hohe intensität
Leuchtet das land am himmel auch wenn das das ein tolles naturspektakel ist hat es seine schattenseiten denn an den polarregionen schützt das er
Nicht fällt weniger manche experten und expertinnen sagen dass es bei aktuellen sonneneruptionen sinnvoll sei
verkehrsflugzeuge andere routen also nicht über die arktis zum beispiel fliegen zu lassen oder grönland
Dieses mal ging der gigantische sonnensturm für die menschheit glimpflich aus ich halte euch hier auf dem laufenden wie sich die
sonnenaktivität jetzt entwickelt und ob noch etwas hinterher kommt hier bei pixum r vater sofort wenn ihr kein video dazu verpassen wollen
Drückt mir hier ein abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht den
auf die glocke hier geht es weiter mit planetenkonstellation
Bolt sonne um auch ein sehr interessantes video draufklicken wenn er mehr wissen wollte und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran